sarebbe alle skype room via vorrei
andare tutti gli oggetti indovinelli
dovrai trovare sta scorrendo 1 sono
ancora qui nel mixtape rom
ma che cosa sono tutte queste scritte
treni dove sarà entrata e ha aggiunto
qualcosa
bene ora concentriamoci dobbiamo
riuscire a capire come scappare da so
delle chiavi nascoste da qualche parte
voi dovete aiutarmi ogni cosa che notate
che pensate possa essere un indizio una
soluzione per scappare da qua scrivetelo
nei commenti quindi tenete gli occhi
bene aperti
proviamo ad esplorare un po e vediamo
ma cosa c'è scritto di prova a scappare
lo sto già facendo premi che così
qualcosa appeso sembra tipo un rov
anello o un dito ma può trovare qualcosa
qualche indizio qualcosa una sorta di
ragnatela
aspetta c'è qualcosa qua qua c'è un
altro di quei verbi o cos'è un dito dito
di g
che tipo ma c'è qualcosa qua dietro
guardate non riesco a non riesco a
prenderlo che cos'è che una carta rossa
e qua dietro c'è uno specchietto
ma cosa serve questa cosa aiutatemi
aiutatemi non so cosa può servire questa
carta strana ma vediamo c'è
qualcos'altro qua e un walkie talkie
pronto pronto a grani ci sei non
risponde nessuno
e c'è una luce
faccio un pulsante è una lucina
ok non so cosa mi può servire
sicuramente c'è qualcos'altro qua a giro
e mi servirà sicuramente per qualcosa
vediamo cos'altro cè intrappolato nel
castello spiritato di grail i fantasmi
aleggiano intorno a te e ti fanno venire
i brividi scappa risolvendo il seguente
indovinello tra le seguenti parole solo
tre sono presenti sui dischetti queste
sono gli indizi trova lì e scopri i
numeri della combinazione fra gli
atelier calderone scopo arancione torta
come in uk a rincari on estiva l'iva
scarico sue parole forse qui in mezzo in
queste cose scritte
o dio li c'e un teschio perché c'è una
freccia forse devo stare attenta al
segnale qua vediamo qua c'è scritto
scappa granny acqua c'è scritto la sua
vita risata ma l'etica di creme e qua
sotto c'è uno con una freccia in
lucchetto e co2 con una freccia
[Musica]
forse devo seguire gli indizi in ordine
quindi immagino che devo iniziare dall
uno mi dice una freccia che punta verso
qua il lucchetto quindi verso quale
questo dito e questa ragnatela
e poi queste cose che ho appena fretta
aspettavo che cos'è questo stiamo
indizio stretta alle skype room via
vorrai andare tutti gli oggetti e
indovinelli dovrai trovare firmato g ok
ora ho capito granny ammesso vari
oggetti e indovinelli sparsi quindi
dovrò risolverli tutti per riuscire a
uscire dall escape room
mi raccomando voi dovete aiutarmi nei
commenti perché io poi vi leggerò così
vediamo se riusciamo risolverli assieme
ma spero già di riuscire a risolvere
qualcosa pensa gestita e ce la possiamo
fare
allora questo non penso che vi serva
proprio un bel niente e quindi occhetto
indicava qua c'è la frizione lucchetto
indicava qua questo messaggio questa
ragnatela
ma
questa giunta si è attaccata la
ragnatela la mano c'è un lucchetto
ma è un po strano questo lucchetto e
stato infilzato dentro questo spatola
quindi immagino che devo riuscire ad
aprirlo per prendere quello che c'è
nella scatola quotiamo meglio vede the
granny lo ha proprio infiltrato dentro
questa povera scatola come funzionerà il
tasto lucchetto devo prendere non
succede niente colmiamo questo succede
niente spetta c'era una luce vedete
lezioni su rossa qua ma non succede
niente maledizione come certi va cosa
devo fare fosse forte indicazione qua
uno lucchetto aiutatemi anche voi ditemi
se vedete qualche indizio qualcosa 3
vediamo se c'è qualcos'altro fa oltre a
questo strano dito verde c'è la
ragnatela
vogliamo la cube e poi la scritta
qualcosa ma con fisco su dei dischetti
degli scritti con delle parole aspetta
guardiamo di meglio forse siamo vicini
alla soluzione allora ci sono vari gli
scherzi scritto scultura
specchio perché al contrario questo
aspetto momento specchio
io avevo uno specchio trovato uno
specchio prima cioè non è proprio uno
specchio ma sembra uno specchio ma se
devo devo fare qualcosa del genere si
può riflettere lo è caduto il dito potrò
toccarlo
va beh l'ho lanciato lì mi sembra un
brutto presentimento
forse vuol dire che ho fatto qualcosa di
giusto o qualcosa di sbagliato comunque
con questo specchio posso riuscire a
leggerlo
a leggere la parola dritta forse sto
guardando la così vedete non so se
riuscite a vedere ma così si legge
normalmente ok quindi forse lo specchio
serve a questo ma cosa serve questo
rosso comunque vediamo cos'altro cè
borsa anche questo altro chario questo
che cosa che cosa c'è scritto ecco la è
impossibile da leggere e qua non c'è
niente invece nonché di colori diversi
ma quindi cosa devo fare
a quasi una fessura possedevo infilare
[Musica]
non succede niente
non penso che devo mettere queste cose
qua dentro proviamo no non funziona
aspetta prima c'era questa cosina strana
che devo capire a cosa funziona questa
luce
proviamo a illuminare qualcosa vediamo
se funziona o forse in questo caso
nostro vediamo non succede niente
guardate e così è un libro ma forse
tutte queste carte al so cosa dietro
questa è una torcia saremo tutti gli
indizi e se scritto bianco ok ora ho
capito
con questo posso rivelare le parole
nella parte del retro di questi
cerchietti e le altre le leggo anche se
nel college e dello stesso calo specie
di capire a cosa serve questo che se
appena staccato notate la rotta
dovevo attaccarlo con una di questi con
questo sfondo rosso
allora mettiamo questo rosso qua e è
comparso è comparso guardate se c'è una
parola non si riesce a leggere bene però
forse lo sporcata un po troppo ma c'è
scritto rosa ok ora ho capito come
leggere queste cose i nostri basta
mettere questo soprattutto il viva le
parole
ok ho capito devo trovare queste parole
ma dove devo metterle aspetta la fessura
di prima forse devo mettere questa carta
della fessura di prima ok penso di aver
capito allora o no guardate il tempo sta
scorrendo può togliere la carta così si
ferma no no buono buono cordate schiaffo
sta scorrendo dello spreco pubblico se
succede altrimenti prove tipologie
trombe crude una pompa dobbiamo trovare
queste parole velocissime allora telone
sta tipa non è solo tre sono presenti su
i dischetti queste sono gli indizi trova
li scoprirò mary o che io credo che
sbrighiamoci allora borsa borsa non ce
ne siamo qua vicino cuscino
non c'è oddio il tempo che scorre mi fa
venire il dubbio rosso rosso c'è andiamo
a chi girarla per controllare allora
vediamo ci siamo qua scritto allora
vediamo quasi ha scritto pezzi knox
spezie non c'è qua dietro c'è il grigio
cerchiamoci allora qua cosa c'è qua c'è
un'immagine di una pagnotta quindi
questo non c'è e cosa c'è il giallo non
vincere anche questo ho trovato neanche
una pila ora il tempo sta passando
allora quasi scritto perde no non
coperte e qualla parole papa non c'è
neanche quest'anno mentre voli anche una
forse ho sbagliato non ho capito come
funziona quasi ha scritto blu allora
facce immagine di una torcia
e tra queste parole io devo trovare una
di queste parole c'è in realtà ne devo
trovare il 3 allora vediamo pace
scomparto che ne ho trovato un lamento
poi da parte o no può solo tre minuti
allora vediamo qualcos'altro qua questi
ha scritto scarpa nome anche questa cioè
e qua c'è scritto broccolo da una seria
anche broccolo la pandera qualche parola
c'è viola non c'è neanche viola nero dai
40 la nazione sia ratio regione bene
manca solo una allora cestino non c'è
vera
oddio solo due minuti c'è una torta no
non è la torta aiuto ketchup questo che
cos'è un orologio scultura non ci
mettiamo questo tavolo il tempo per un
libro non c'è specchio non c'è
l'ultimo cartellino questa è la mia
ultima speranza il bianco non c'e
neanche guasto o di fondo allora
sbagliato ha sbagliato
che però manca petizione tavolo non lo
trovo però sposerà tutto qua che cosa
c'è scritto viola riesca viola c'era
tanta forza torta libro bianco orologio
tavolo o no sta scorrendo il tempo come
il prezzo non trovo l'altra parola lei
come un palazzo che potrebbero inoltre
parola vanno troppo e li controlliamo
tutto tempo sta scadendo
[Musica]
allora questa è una torta ma non c'è
hanno scritto ricco è tosta ok salute 3
o che cosa devo fare adesso compare
potevo fare allora
un'immagine colorata e forse con lei ed
a questo c'è scritto neve ok 12 quello
giallo e 4 meno 234 che lo sai che cosa
che non è la torta 5
[Applauso]
capisco è così aperta
ok siamo tiro fuori
evviva ce l'abbiamo fatta vediamo ora
cosa sta in questa scatola non e aprila
ma c'è già luce cosa me ne faccio di una
pila
mi aspettavo qualcosa di meglio
metteteci anche un biglietto c'è scritto
se i prossimi indizi vuoi rivelare la
luce via dovrà andare firmato granny se
fossi menti sicuri venerare la dolce
vita dovrà andare
che cosa significa secondo voi cioè io
ho aperto questo lucchetto giusto per
trovare un altro indovinello è una
cavolo di pila la luce via dovrà andare
ma se deve andar via la luce perché mi
dà una pila capisco
[Musica]
i blu questa pila fa un po paura però
perché dice che deve andare via la luce
penso che la dovrò usare accendere no
pizzo scrivetemi voi nei commenti cosa
fu dopo voler dire la luce via deve
andare
se mi ha dato una luce quindi forse non
la devo accendere ma allora cosa vi
serve
o forse devo usare solo questa luce e
come faccio a far a dire andare via le
altre luci diamo ei non ti muovere da o
dio si muove da sola guardate toglietelo
bloccata una pila di g stregata guardate
oddio perché si muove da solo fa paura
forse questo è l'altro indizio la luce
via dovrei andare nel senso che si deve
spostare da qualche parte
vediamo doveva andare così mettiamo si è
bloccata li ha in effetti qua mi ero
dimenticata che c'è la seconda parte
quindi forse devo guardare o qualche
altro il dominella
questa parte ha scritto prova a scappare
ma se la luce mia deve andare dove ora
non si muove più
ho paura che può muoversi così da sola
però punta sempre lì
quindi vuol dire che devo risolvere il
secondo indovinello ma dov'è il secondo
indovinello se sono scritto prova a
scappare una presa un teschio
proviamo a cercare bene vediamo c'è
qualcosa di nascosto con la guardate se
un interruttore prova spenderlo magari
la luce pietà per andare vuol dire che
devo spegnere la luce guardia tra poco
arriva remo completamente al buio ma c'è
l'altro che paura
beh treni qual è stata la soluzione o
spento le luci come mi hai chiesto ma
non succede niente
non ricorda neanche dove ho messo anche
o la pila proviamo accendere la pila
guardate si illumina anche queste dita
strane che illuminano e tutto scritto
con un inchiostro luminoso
forse a questo indizio qua c'è una
freccia e degli strani pallini una ics e
un teschio con delle ossa e cuoce
un'altra hicks e una ragnatela
wow è bellissimo se illumina tutto però
non capisco perché devo vedere tutto con
questa luce lasciano adito ce n'è uno
anche quasi questo è quello di prima
e c'è anche questo ma cosa devo fare
adesso
non capisco ok proviamo a seguire i
numeri qua 1 ed era il lucchetto e l'ho
già risolto poi la risata di grendi non
penso che c'entri niente
poi c'è una freccia 2 che passa di qua
io penso che le dita c'entrino qualcosa
voi cosa ne pensate
comunque qua non c'è più scritto niente
poi qua c'è scritto prova a scappare non
so se vuole dire qualcosa o da dietro
c'è un altro dito quando è quello che ho
buttato io qua c'è un teschio e qua c'è
l'altra freccia quindi forte l'altro
indovinello e questo e l'altra freccia
porta a questi puntini e questo strano
non artiglio non c'è nient'altro
cuociono hicks vediamo bene in ogni
angolo picco sempre c'è qualcosa che ho
fatto perché quindi vuol dire che granny
vuole che disegno qualcosa anch'io
cosa dovrei di segnare
[Musica]
secondo voi cosa devo disegnare un
teschio
forse questi pallini come quel gioco in
cui devi unire i pallini e disegnare
qualcosa
proviamo io ci provo non penso che sia
la soluzione giusta
[Musica]
ma ci prova lo stesso allora ecco qua ok
proviamo
ho paura
[Musica]
che abbiamo quasi finito il disegno
ecco adatto ma sentito un rumore strano
e cosenza
spero che non sia niente che arriva qua
come si illumina con la ragnatela
comunque ho unito il tutto forse ora
devo per riaccendere la luce perché
altrimenti non si vede
ok ho riacceso alla luce e non mi sembra
che sia apparso niente di la prima
continuiamo per si consola che paura
avanti e indietro
questi affari dirmi sta puntando verso
limpido comunque fa ho fatto il disegno
ma non è comparso niente l'unica cosa è
che sembra ancora di più una sorta di
artigli ma voi cosa sembra aspetta forse
può sembrare più una mano ci sono 1 2 3
4 5
sì una mano
provo a poggiare la mia mano forse
succede qualcosa non è successo niente
ma perché ho dovuto disegnare una mano
non capisco aiutami tu pila perché ho
dovuto disegnare una mano dirmi forse
dovuto trovare qualche altro indizio
provo a spegnere le luci nuovamente
aspetta forse una mano e in queste
scritture pieno di vita quindi insomma
vuol dire che devo ricreare un altro
mano qualcosa del genere
o forse posso provare ad appoggiare le
dita nella mano si sembra un po strano
così proviamo devo prima trovarle tutte
allora pure e questa sicuramente si vede
subito strano togliere un dito e non so
se il dito giusto maledizione questa
risposta no lapillo si sta scaricando
come faccio a maledizione che però pare
forse ho sbagliato dito proviamo
l'indice è rimasto per fortuna
ok ora devo solo trovare e altre dita
un'acqua sicuramente perché lui non sa
prima e l'altro dito ok provato
attaccare anche questo quale potrebbe
essere questo mi sembra un po più corto
forse il mignolo
proviamo o meglio fifa è rimasto
guardate ci sono già due dita nella mano
ora attendiamo dove sono le altre a un
era lì a quella l'ho già messa vedete
qualcosa di verde
sicuramente queste sono già attaccate
saperti ora sarà sopra si è proprio un
dito
evviva eccolo qua ok presto abbiamo un
altro dito ok quale subito sarà questo
prima cerco anche gli altri così potete
aiutarmi a cercarli certo questo era
quello di prima che rimaneva peso ecco
fatto quanti ne mancano 1 2 o 3 al 4 ne
manca solo uno è viva essere controllate
se riuscite a vederlo c'è qualcosa
diverte ecco l'ultimo dita evviva
ora ho provato attaccarli tutti e vedo
che succede speriamo che sia la
soluzione
ok andiamo ad attaccare un'altra vita mi
mancano solo due
non vedo l'ora di vedere cosa succederà
ora l'ultimo questo è l'ultimo dito e
ora finalmente scopriremo cosa succede
una volta che attacco tutte le dita
guardate che luce che emana questo dito
sono diventata tutta verde la
maledizione del verde è sempre presente
wow sembra una pila ok andiamo a me cose
l'ultimo dito
[Musica]